foreign
[Music]
the post-apocalyptic action movie Mad
Max Fury Road overtook the movie scene
and left a lasting impression on fans
and critics alike and this was not only
recognized at the box office in 2016 the
film won a total of six Oscars
particularly in Creative areas such as
production design makeup and sound it
quickly became apparent that more movies
would be made before the story around
Max rocketansky has continued in Mad Max
the Wasteland however director George
Miller has devoted himself to another
character imperator furiosa a prequel
will tell the story of how she became
the badass fighter we saw in Mad Max
Fury Road since the movie titled furiosa
won't be released before 2024. we want
to fuel your anticipation a little by
providing you with all the info about
the cast plot and production in this
video
the movie will be said about 20 years
before the events of Fury Road of course
the desert world is still the same but
the political situation will likely be a
tad different in contrast to the last
part of the Mad Max film series The Plot
is supposed to cover a period of 15
years so we can most likely expect a
detailed character development of the
then still young female Warrior
an official synopsis of the film was
released a while back so together with
the known backstories of the characters
we can already predict quite a few
things about the plot of furiosa at the
beginning of the storyline furiosa still
lives in the green place of many mothers
she won't stay there for long as she
tells us at the end of the last film she
has been gone for 7 000 days that
corresponds roughly to the mentioned 20
years difference to Fury Road as already
narrated there she is kidnapped from her
home she falls into the hands of a biker
horde led by the warlord dementas since
the film is supposed to cover a longer
period of time it will probably go into
more detail about her time in this harsh
environment and how these challenges
change her as a character on their raids
dementis and his group finally encounter
immortan Joe and the Citadel a war
ensues between the two sides in the
midst of this battle for Supremacy
furiosa must pass many trials to find
her way home according to the official
plot of course connoisseurs of the
predecessor know that you will
ultimately stay in the Citadel the
question remains however whether she
will join a Morton Joe of her own free
will or whether you keep her as a kind
of War trophy we're also excited to find
out how young furiosa will lose her arm
footage on set shows Anya Taylor Joy
wearing a glove which can be reworked by
CGI afterwards so she will certainly
have to endure some physical suffering
it also remains exciting to see her own
Mother's story is going to be explored
we can imagine her sacrificing herself
for her daughter in some way or another
quite a bit is already known about the
cast and we also know some of the
antagonists besides furiosa among them
are a few names that leave a lot of room
for speculation
20 years before Fury Road furiosa did
not bear the title of imperator nor was
she likely to already appear so hardened
the big time difference between the two
stories means that the rule had to be
recast Charlize Theron who plays the
role of furiosa in Fury Road certainly
won't be too sad about this decision she
repeatedly lamented the conditions on
set and the working relationship with
her acting colleague Tom Hardy after the
last film even though they initially
considered using computer animation in
order to make the actress look younger a
good alternative for throne was finally
found the young furiosa is played by
none other than Anya Taylor Joy after
her role in the Netflix series the
Queen's Gambit at the latest she is
regarded as a new star in Hollywood and
was also more than impressive in her
last Productions the northmen and the
menu
let's turn our attention to dementis the
warlord is the leader of a biker horde
and the one who kidnaps furiosa from the
green place of many mothers the leader
of the biker horde was originally meant
to be played by Yaya Abdul Mateen II
however it is still not known why the
actor was substituted shortly before
filming began yet his supposed successor
is no stranger either the warlord in the
new film will presumably be played by
none other than Marvel star Chris
Hemsworth who can already be seen in
photos from the set with a massive beard
we say presumably because there is still
some conjecture about the role
distribution we'll get to that in a
moment
when it comes to furiosa another
character can't be missing in Morton Joe
he is also a lot younger and gets a new
actor this is necessary because his
previous actor Hugh Keys Byrne passed
away in 2020. after all he already
played the bad guy in the first Mad Max
movie from 1979. who exactly would play
the role now is not entirely clear yet
Tom Burke a cast member whose role has
not been revealed yet is assumed to play
the part he is known from the Netflix
movie mank and the oscar-nominated
living and this is where the speculation
starts neither Tom Burke nor Chris
Hemsworth have been officially assigned
to their roles yet it's true though that
most are certain that Hemsworth will
take on the central role of dementas but
there's also the theory that he will
triumph over Berks and Morton Joe at the
end of the film and then take over his
name just as the new religious leader of
the Citadel
and Morton Joe's youngest son rictus
erectus will also be seen again as in
Fury Road he will again be played by
Nathan Jones the six foot ten tall guy
was last seen in the new film version of
Mortal Kombat it will be interesting to
see how the creators will portray him
after all Jones is 13 years older than
Chris Hemsworth and 12 years older than
Tom Burke tricky in case they're
supposed to portray his biological
father
Angus Sampson is another actor we
already know from Fury Road he will
appear once again as the Citadel doctor
organic mechanic the doctor is not only
responsible for the medical care of the
war boys but also delivers the children
of a Morton Joe in the film he's also
the only one who addresses the leader
simply as Joe or boss what kind of
perfidious experiments and medical
interventions he will perform in furiosa
remains to be seen
also part of the cast are Elsa Pataki
who also played in Thor love and thunder
and Ian Roberts who some of you might
remember from Superman Returns one actor
we are very excited about is Young Quaid
and Bales the boy from Australia who has
a form of dwarfism was bullied so much
at school because of his looks that he
didn't want to live anymore and
published this in a video message in the
meantime he has had several film
requests and after the film 3000 years
of longing with Idris Elba until the
Swinton furiosa is the second film in
which he has managed to get a role
as with the other Mad Max Parts George
Miller will of course be in charge of
directing again the 78 year old
Mastermind behind the scenes is
indispensable in his position and is
already planning the upcoming
installments another reason for the
prequel is co-writer Nicola thoris who
already created a detailed background
story for each main character in Fury
Road the script for furiosa was
therefore already written during the
filming of the last movie however since
there were disputes between Miller and
Warner Brothers further progress was put
on hold for the time being also back are
lots of vehicles while there were 135 in
the 2015 film there to be several more
this time it is clear that the Oscar for
the best production design is being
aimed for again filming started in early
2021 in New South Wales Australia and
over 850 new jobs were created and 350
million dollars invested in local
infrastructure for the movie alone after
filming was completed in late 2022
london-based d-nag also moved
post-production to Australia not only
does this substantiate the size of the
project but also created an additional
500 jobs Tom Hardy will likewise return
to the franchise after furiosa with Mad
Max the Wasteland the title for the next
movie is already known then again with
Max rocketansky in the leading role but
this shall not be the last movie of the
franchise according to rumors there will
be a seventh film for now though we are
looking forward to furiosa the movie is
scheduled to hit theaters on May 24th
that was it all the latest info on Mad
Max furiosa are you excited to immerse
yourself in the desert landscape of this
post-apocalyptic world again and while
Anya Taylor Joy be a worthy successor to
Charlize Theron let us know your views
in the comments and if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up thanks
for watching see you next time
[Music]